có thể mặt dưới đẹp
thì đây là một hình xin hả dị
thì tôi đánh đây là một chuẩn bị
quá
khoảng lòng lại một chạc
thái sao là một chuẩn bị giúp emy nhé
tôi đánh
đây là 2h14h20
mình giúp
2 lên liên tiếp
để phí chi bình dơ thì khoảng cái này
thì nó cái này thì mình giống như nó
mình giống như nó của mình giống như nó của mình
bây giờ nó cũng chút tây
nó cũng chút tây là nè
đừng biết nó ngon nhá
tôi từng như 1 2 đi bất kỳ luôn
thì cho 1 2 đi bất kỳ này
đây là 2 đi bất kỳ này
đi bất kỳ này mà thì này
nó cũng là 2 đi bụng trạc thái
nó chú tìm đủ
mình giống như nó gon achy
để cho 2 đi bất kỳ này
mình giống như nó là 2 đi bất kỳ này
1 đi bất kỳ này là 2 đi bất kỳ này
cho 2 đi bất kỳ này là 1 всю kind
thì nó không xác là lì nhật, một chạc là lợp
và con hoàn cạnh hết, tôi nghĩ nó sẽ là một chạc là lợp
Vì quá, ai, ngồi ra thì chúng ta có thể xác đi, chủ ki vỡ rõ khoảng găng là mẹ nữa
bởi ra này thì con khoảng cơ bản thôi, nó là chia nhỏ, không có kể, rồi mình xí là
ở đây, là dành em như nhá, nó sẽ có cao vị xí đốt, là mình chỉ di, cân bằng,
viên giống, cân bằng, viên giống, cân bằng, viên giống,
cân bằng, đúng không? thì em có nhiều này, khoảng cơ ra mà chúng ta sẽ vi tử vị xí thì có à đẹp,
tử vị xí, cân bằng, để ra vị xí biệt, cứ cân bằng ra biệt là mất khoảng là tây xí bụt,
quá, khoảng cơ biệt lúc để cân bằng, cái khoảng nhỏ nhỏ nhỏ nhỏ,
khoảng cơ biệt, đây quá, khoảng cơ biệt,
hả, nó sẽ làm một tây xí bụt, bây giờ mà tương người như vậy,
liên tự cân bằng này, liên tân bằng kia thân nó sẽ là tây xí thái,
thái nhỏ, đúng không? liên tự cân bằng này, tân bằng kia xà tây xí thái,
và đi tử vị, mình xíu, mê biệt,
quá, nó có sẽ là tây xí thái,
hả, nó tử vị và chứ tỏ tị, nhiều khi là nó sẽ còn viên một đường mình xíi ngay hốt,
nó không nhiều đường mình xí, nhưng nó có thể xác định rử dụt ở khoảng gà là viên này,
bây giờ,
ok, không dưới nhé nó sẽ còn những bài khó,
thì chúng ta mới dự vào các vị chỉ của bật,
quá, chúng ta bị viểu,
chúng ta bị chỉ bò lên của bật ra,
chúng ta sẽ đi khó quen,
nó đã đi vào những người ta tụng,
bình như ra, cái thằng chúc kì,
nó sẽ là những bài khó,
còn những bài xalic cơ bản,
nó mà chúc kì mà thì chỉ vì thí rất kì khu kì,
thì chỉ rất là là nhà đúng,
thì nó rất là rất, đúng không?
là khoảng gàng bật là phạm một chẳng phải gọi,
bây giờ,
ok, nào thì bây giờ thì chúng ta sẽ thử rồi,
là hay có nổ như ngân thà,
đó thì em muốn xa định chúc kì vô của nướng thà,
còn những cuy lợn nhật,
thường nhất là em sẽ choa thành một hình xin hoàn trị,
nó nó có lửa đau được cuối,
nó không? Đây, phải choa hình xin hoàn,
đây là một hình xin hoàn trị,
nó là y đầu thì có nó là cái bây giờ thì đấy,
cho nó một chúc kì,
cho cho kì của nó sẽ tự hôm 1 năm,
mình một cái năng nó,
thì chúc kì của nó mà nhớ,
bây giờ,
bây giờ mình không có hợi,
nó có hợi,
nó có hợi của chúng ta là cái là thường đúng ai thôi,
nó không có cái này,
bây giờ mình tự hôm 1 năm,
nó có nó ăn một bờ chúng kì,
nó không phải năng lên nó phải năng,
nó không có hợi,
nó có xói nó là chúc kì lợn,
nó có hợi hợi,
nó có hợi hợi hợi hợi hợi,
nó có chá cơn,
nó không,
đi từ vị chỉ thì có vị chỉ bàn đầu,
nó vị chỉ biệt này,
đến vị chỉ tây của hợi năng đây là vị chỉ cần bàn,
thì đây nó là tây xin bố,
nó có tây xin bố nó chỉ là bàn nhớ,
vị từ không, nó không phải năng đây là có năng,
nó có thể gọi xin dà,
tây gọi xin dà, tây gọi có bây hàn,
tây bỏ hãi rồi,
nó có thể chuya cho hãi rồi,
nó có đúng không,
có đúng không,
có bỏ gố xong cách,
nó sẽ đi,
nó có thể gọi nó sẽ bảo,
nó có xong mạy thì sẽ có những cách,
nó sẽ có những mạy đó hô,
nó không sẽ có bàn,
nó có thể gọi bà,
nó có một xong dí đầu,
nó sẽ mình tướng,
nó có thể gọi xin dù,
nó có thể gọi bàn,
nó có thể gọi bàn trên một thế nào,
nó có thể gọi không soạn ở 2,5 hói cho 2,5 hói cho 2,5 hói cho 2,5 hói cho 2,5 hói cho 2,5 hói cho 3,5,
các hói xin bín,
nó có bín này mình kia nè,
nó là bánh nhau,
nó 1 nơi ở chúc y,
nó 2,
nó đi từ cân màn ngay thì cân màn kia,
nó sẽ là 1 nơi ở chúc y,
nó có bánh đi từ đây,
Cân bằng đến bến, không phải bình bình bằng tư trước khi...
rất nhiều cái những xây.
Bây giờ, trước khi có đàn hoàn nhiều mấy.
Đừng nhận, đàn hoấy bún đây, đàn hoấy bún đây.
Đàn hoấy bún đây, đàn hoấy bún đây.
Đàn hoấy bún đây.
Tìa tên 2, đàn hoấy bún đây.
Tìa tên hoấy bún đây.
Tìa hoấy bún đây.